ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING JUNE THIRTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND TING CALLING FOR
MEMBERS THIS IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WELCOME TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS TO GO OVER BEFORE WE START.
MISTER SPEAKER HAS APPOINTED TO
NEW COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME LOSE THREE
OF US AND LOSE WELCOME IN REPLY
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE A PART
OF THIS COMMITTEE S WELL AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUSTIN GABRIEL
WHO WILL BE HERE SHORTLY.
WE UPDATE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY THREE ITEMS ARE PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SP FIVE TO DO
FIVE TWENTY TWO GLACIER.
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. NINE ZERO
SEVEN CANNELLA.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE HERNANDEZ.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS
BILLS INSIDE IN ORDER.
OUR FIRST BILL TODAY IS SP ONE
ZERO THREE FIVE AND I DON'T SEE
MISS JACKSON HERE.
SO WE WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
MOVE DOWN [inaudible]
TO I'M STUNT.
WELL WE NEED TO SCHOOLS AND WE
NEED TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
TODAY.
AND THE SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM
WE WILL --
GO FORWARD SO WE'LL START WITH --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR MISTER WILL
GROW OLD [inaudible]
NNOVA [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
SO WOULDN'T YOU KNOW WE'LL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO START WITH
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE US SENATOR DODD SP NINE
FOURTEEN SO HAPPY YOU COULD JOIN
US TODAY.
AND TIMELY TIMELY.
WELL THE OLD MAN COULD STILL RUN.
SO BRING IT PRE WITH OPENING
STATEMENTS.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TODAY AND PRESENTING SP
NIGHT FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD
EXPAND THE AUTHORITY OF COUNTIES.
TO DELIVER PROJECTS USED IN THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK OR
CMA ARE.
SEYMOUR DOT CONTRACTING METHOD.
SEE MARK CONTRACT IS
COMPETITIVELY PROCURED.
CONTRACT FOR PROJECT THE
GUARANTEES THE COST OF THE
PROJECT IN FURNISHES
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT SERVICES.
PROJECTS THAT HAVE MULTIPLE
PHASES LEND THEMSELVES TO THIS
METHOD.
BECAUSE THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT CAN PER.
AT DIFFERENT TIMES.
AUTHORIZING THIS METHOD
PROCUREMENT WILL PROVIDE
COUNTIES WITH THE NECESSARY TOOL
TO DELIVER FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
ENSURE HIGH QUALITY CONSTRUCTION
AT A GUARANTEED MAXIMUM PRICE.
REDUCE PUBLIC SECTOR LIABILITY
AND IS SURE MORE TIMELY
COMPLETION OF PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED SEE MARK TO BE USED
FOR BUILDING PROJECTS IN THAT
PROPOSAL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SP NIGHT FOURTEEN GRANTS
COUNTIES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BUILD PROJECTS THEY NEED IN THE
MOST EFFICIENT MANNER POSSIBLE
WHICH TRANSLATES TO SAVINGS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND TAXPAYERS
LIKE.
WITH ME TODAY ARE KIANA KIANA
VALENTINE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES BILL
SPONSOR.
AND ARTIE CON THE DEPUTY PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR IN ORANGE COUNTY
SENATOR DODD I HOPE YOU DON'T
MIND SINCE WE'VE GOT A QUORUM
HERE WOULD LIKE TO DO A ROLL
CALL FIRST AND THERE WILL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY.
TO HEAR THIS SUPPORT FOR YOUR
BILL.
HI AGUIAR-CURRY HERE ADWARE
CURRY HERE WALDRON BLOOM
CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON HERE LACKEY GRIEVOUS.
REAVIS HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HERE.
I DON'T CONTINUE --
YOUR SUPPORTERS.
FEEL FREE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
I AS THE SENATOR STATED THE
PURPOSE OF NINE FOURTEEN IS TO
EXPAND THE TOOLS COUNTIES HAVE
TO PLAN AND DELIVER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
IN A TIMELY EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER.
AT WHILE THE TRADITIONAL METHOD
OF DESIGN BID BUILD AYE IS AN
APPROPRIATE DELIVERY METHOD FOR
MANY TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SOME COUNTIES HAVE FOUND SUCCESS
USING ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY
METHOD SUCH AS DESIGN BUILD AND
SEE MARK. NINE FOURTEEN PROVIDES
AN ADDITIONAL OPTION AND I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT IT IS AN
OPTION IT TOOL IN THE TOOL KIT
TO DELIVER COMPLEX PROJECTS WITH
MULTIPLE BENEFITS.
SUCH AS EARLY CONTRACTOR
INVOLVEMENT COST PREDICTABILITY
ENHANCE SCHEDULE CONTROLS AND
RISK MITIGATION --
AT THE SENATOR MENTIONED ARTIE
CON IS C. SACKS RESIDENT EXPERT
ON SEA MAR SO I WANTED TO FOR A
MAJORITY OF MY TIME. TO HURT TO
TALK ABOUT THAT ASPECTS OF SEA
MAR THAT I THINK THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE INTERESTED IN BUT I DID
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE.
THAT NINE FOURTEEN MERELY
EXPANDS EXISTING COUNTY
AUTHORITY TO OTHER TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS WE ARE
NOT AMENDING THE PROJECT COSTS
THRESHOLD IN NEW LA ALREADY OF
ONE MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE.
IT DOES NOT AMEND THE SKILLED
TRAINED WORKFORCE PROVISIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
UNANIMOUSLY AND AB EIGHT FIVE
ONE JUST LAST YEAR.
I S. B. NINE FOURTEEN DOESN'T
CHANGE THE WAY IN WHICH THE
CONTRACT IS COMPETITIVELY
PROCURED AND LASTLY A THE
EXISTING SEA MAR THIRTY IS SET
TO SUNSET AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SO THE LEGISLATURE WILL
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW SEA MAR.
THIRTY AND ITS APPLICATION TO
THESE OTHER TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN JUST
A FEW YEARS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON --
DOWN CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NOT ECONOMY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC WORKS.
AND I JUST WANTED TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHAT SEE MAR IS AND WHAT
IT DOES --
AND I'LL BE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS TRADITIONAL METHOD OF
DESIGN FIT BUILT A CONTRACTOR IS
SPECIFICALLY PRECLUDED BY LAW
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE DESIGN
PHASE OF THE PROJECT.
THIS CREATES A SITUATION WHERE
IN THE COUNTY AND ITS DESIGNER
WORK TOGETHER TO PRODUCE A PLAN --
SPECIFICATIONS AND ESTIMATES
ONLY TO HAND OF THOSE OVER TO A
CONTRACTOR THAT HAS HAD NO
INVOLVEMENT IN THE PROCESS UNTIL
THE PROJECT IS ADVERTISE WHAT
COMES IN LATE --
CONVERSELY THE SEA MAR MEANT
THAT --
REQUIRES THAT THE MOST QUALIFIED
CONTRACTOR PARTICIPATE IN THE
DESIGN PHASE UP PROVIDING
CONSTRUCTIVE BILLY REVIEWS VALUE
ENGINEERING ALTERNATIVES AND
GUARANTEED MAXIMUM PRICE.
WOULD SEE MARK COST ESCALATIONS
ARE MITIGATED THROUGH THE EARLY
INVOLVEMENT OF THE CONTRACTOR
SELECTED AS THE MOST QUALIFIED
TO BUILD A SPECIFIC PROJECT.
ADDITIONALLY THE CONTRACTORS
REQUIRED INVOLVEMENT IN THE
DESIGN PHASE ALLOWS FOR A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
RESOLVING ISSUES AND ALLOWS THE
CONTRACTOR TO RECOMMEND DESIGNED
ADJUSTMENTS THAT BETTER ALIGNED
WITH HOW THE CONTRACTOR PLANS TO
BUILD THE PROJECT.
FINALLY THE CONTRACT IS AFFORDED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH OR
INFORMATION TO BETTER COMPLETELY
GUARANTEED MAXIMUM PRICE.
THROUGH EARLY INVOLVEMENT BY THE
MOST QUALIFIED CONTRACTOR WE
FEEL THAT THE OPPORTUNITY IS
ENHANCE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
SCHEDULE THAT HAS HIGHER SUCCESS
RATE FOR ON TIME DELIVERY.
ALSO THE TRADITIONAL ARE LOW BUT
PROCESS ONLY GUARANTEES LOWEST
INITIAL PRICE AND IN ALMOST ALL
CASES WE SEE --
ARE CHANGE ORDERS I DID WHEN WE
HAVE COMPLEX PROJECTS --
IN SUMMARY THE SEA MAR DELIVERY
METHOD IS BEST UTILIZED FOR
COMPLEX HIGH RISK PROJECTS WITH
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS WERE
BUDGET AND SCHEDULE CONSTRAINTS
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN.
UNFORTUNATELY COUNTIES ARE
CURRENTLY LIMITED FROM UTILIZING
SEEM ARE ONLY EXCEPT FOR OWNED
OR LEASED BUSINESS A BUILDINGS
EXCUSE ME.
I'M CLOSING THE SEA MAR A
DELIVERY METHOD IS AN OPTION FOR
INCREASING THE RATE OF SUCCESS
FOR MAJOR CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
AND COUNTY SIMPLY DESIRE TO BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THE RIGHT TOOL
FOR THE RIGHT JOB AN SP NINE
FOURTEEN GIVES THE COUNTIES
ANOTHER TOOL IN OUR TOOLBOX SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND HAVE BEEN ANSWERING
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE OTHERS UP.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR
ANOTHER MEMBER SOME HOMEGROWN
LOW ON THE BILL TODAY NAPA
COUNTY BOARDS TO ROGERS A
POPULAR IN SPORT THANK YOU.
THINK.
DANIEL GLASS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL WHAT WOMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
CHILDREN FOR SOME HAVE THE URBAN
CANS OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THE COMMAND CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HAVE BEEN MADAM CHAIR MIKE
MONICA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL.
AND THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
OF SHEET METAL WORKERS ALSO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER NEW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS CAN STONE HERE
ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS
AND CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA EVEN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION TO THE BILL
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK OF
CONCEPTS AND APPLAUD THE AUTHOR.
I AND COUNTIES FOR SEEKING
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY --
HOWEVER THERE'S A PROVISION IN
THE BILL THAT DISADVANTAGES --
A. B. C. MEMBER COMPANIES AS
COMPARED TO A UNION CONTRACTORS
THAT THE PROVISION IN THE BILL
THAT EXEMPTS LABOR FROM THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS IF THERE'S A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT ENFORCED.
BAN THAT SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS DON'T
APPLY WE THINK THAT WHAT'S GOOD
FOR THE GOOSE IS GOOD FOR THE
GANDER IF A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENT --
IS APPROPRIATE IT SHOULD APPLY
TO EVERYBODY SO ON WITHOUT ME
THIS NOTE ARE RESPECTFUL AND
OPPOSITION UNLESS THE BILL IS TO
AMENDED TO REMOVE APPARITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
US SURE SOME REMEMBER VOEPEL.
SENATOR ARE YOU WILLING TO AMEND
THE BILL.
SOCIETY WITH EVERY BILL WE'RE
GONNA BE.
WITH THIS THIS IS A STELLAR.
FOR I WILL LOOK AT AYE I'M NOT
GONNA MAKE GUARANTEE ANYTHING
RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT I'VE GOT
TALK TO THE BILL'S SPONSOR BUT
THAT THAT'S BEEN MY MODUS
OPERANDI HERE FOR FOUR YEARS IS
TO WORK WITH EVERYBODY TO TRY TO
GET THE BEST BILL THAT WE CAN.
THANK YOU PAINTED AT THEIR OTHER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY SEEN NONE --
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE THE
MOST WE NEED A SECOND.
THANKS WE HAVE A SECOND --
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
OKAY --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WE REALLY PREACH I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
HORROR OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A LOT
OF OLD INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS TO
BE FIXED ANYWAY WE CAN DO IT.
AND GIVING ANOTHER OPTION
ANOTHER OPTION THE TO ONLY
BETTER SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT --
SECRETARY CALLED.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY I'VE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO KABIRA AYE
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL [inaudible]
NO.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR THANK YOU WITH
APOLOGIES TO SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SO NOW WE WILL DO ITEM NUMBER
SIX A SENATOR JACKSON S. B. ONE
ZERO THREE FIVE WELCOME SENATOR
THANK YOU.
PLEASURE TO BE HERE MADAM CHAIR.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS S. BE TEN THIRTY FIVE OF
A BILL THAT PROVIDES A CLEAR.
REGULAR AND FLEXIBLE UPDATE
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO FOLLOW WHEN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCY.
IN THEIR GENERAL PLANNING.
THIS BILL --
PROVIDES AN UPDATE SCHEDULE. TO
THIS CRITICAL SECTION OR I
SHOULD SAY REINSTATES AN UPDATE
SCHEDULE TO THIS CRITICAL
SECTION OF GENERAL PLAN LAW THAT
WAS ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH.
A BILL I AUTHORED S. B..
THREE SEVENTY NINE AND ITS SETS
FORTH THE REQUIREMENT THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST UPDATE THEIR
SAFETY ELEMENT FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
STRATEGIES WHEN THEY UPDATE
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT.
OR THEIR LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN WHICHEVER SERVES THE LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS BETTER.
THIS PROVISION STILL REQUIRES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO UPDATE
THEIR SAFETY ELEMENTS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
ALLOWING NO MORE THAN EIGHT
YEARS BETWEEN UPDATES.
AND THIS UPDATE REQUIREMENT
REQUIRES FREQUENT BUT FLEXIBLE
APPROACHES ENSURING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REGULARLY UPDATE
THEIR GENERAL PLANS AS NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS EMERGE
AND OF COURSE WE KNOW.
THAT WITH CLIMATE CHANGE AND NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS A
OCCURRING AS A RESULT WHETHER
ITS FIRES WHETHER IT'S FLOODS
THAT HAVE.
A RECONFIGURED THE LANDSCAPE AND
THOSE CHANGED ARE THE OF FLOOD
PLANNING IN FLIGHT CONTROL
ISSUES OF AN AREA.
JUST AS A WILD EXAMPLE
HYPOTHETICAL OF COURSE.
ABOUT WHICH IS IN FACT OCCURRED
IN IN MY COMMUNITY --
IT WILL --
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
FLEXIBLE APPROACHES --
THAT WHILE PROVIDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE OPTION TO
COMPLY BASED ON THEIR LOCAL
NEEDS THIS IS VERY LOCALLY
CENTERED.
OF THE ORIGINAL REQUIREMENT FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE ADAPTATION OF PLANNING
WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN NOW WE ARE ADDING
CLIMATE IMPACT ASSISTING LIST
THAT INCLUDES FIRES AND FLOODS
WHICH AT THE TIME WISHING IS
UNUSUAL.
BUT INCREASINGLY FREQUENT SADLY
AND WE KNOW NOW THE CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS ARE BECOMING THE NEW
NORMAL.
AND WITH MAJOR FIRES OCCURRING
IN VIRTUALLY EVERY DISTRICT IN
THE STATE.
INCLUDING MY DISTRICT AND I KNOW
THE CHAIRS DISTRICT IN PERHAPS --
AS A LOOK AROUND OTHERS IN THIS
ROOM PUBLISHING --
AND SO WE REALLY MUST --
REQUIRE --
BUT IS FLEXIBLY AS POSSIBLE THAT
WE A ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AS
PART OF OUR GENERAL PLAN
UPDATING AND IT IS SO I THINK OF
SOME.
MODEST BILL THAT THE REALLY THAT
SIGNIFICANT BILL WAS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN HERE WHICH TRUST MAKING
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO PURSUE
THIS.
SERIES OF QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS
AS THOSE PLANS CONTINUE TO BE
UPDATED AND HERE WITH ME TODAY%
IS KYLE JONES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER.
A OF THE SIERRA CLUB.
AND LAUREN TO VALENCIA OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALL JONES WAS
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING A
LETTER AND I CLEARLY NEED TO
PLAN BETTER FOR GEO.
AS THE SENATOR STATED WE AS AS
CLIMATE SCIENCE IS GETTING
BETTER AND WE'RE UNDERSTANDING
MORE ABOUT HOW THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT AROUND US IS
CHANGING WE'RE LEARNING THAT
PASTORS AND AND AND CONTRAST TO
FREEZE CAN STRIKE IN IN AREAS WE
NEVER THOUGHT BEFORE --
WITH SEA LEVEL RISE HAPPENING WE
NEED TO PLAN FOR THAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT AS THE OCEAN WARMS
HURRICANES ARE EXPANDING THEIR
RANGE.
ARE WE LOSING OUR SNOW MAC AND
WE'RE INCREASINGLY SEEING
FLOODING AND THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT NOW TO SAVE LIVES AND
SAVE MONEY FRANKLY AND IN THE
FUTURE AND AND AND MAKE SURE
THAT -- WE
ARE IF WE HADN'T BATTLED WITH
THE ENVIRONMENT OR WORKING WITH
OUR CHANGE ENVIRONMENT. TO TO TO
TO STILL BE ABLE TO ADAPT TO OUR
FUTURE AND IT'S A WEEKS.
IT'S FOR THIS BILL INNER DRIVE
VOTE TODAY THINKING.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LAUREN
DE VALENCIA REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
ALSO PLEASED TO BE HERE AND
SUPPORT TODAY.
I'M CERTAINLY --
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING I'M TO
PAST EXPERIENCES AS WELL AS
PLANNING FOR ON THE UNFORTUNATE --
AFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH
IS A VERY REAL AS WE'VE SEEN IN
THE PAST YEAR AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY ON
THAT SENATOR JACKSON HAS LED IN
THIS BILL TO AND ALLOW UPDATES.
ON BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
JURISDICTIONAL AND THOSE UPDATES
ARE MADE SO WITH THAT WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR
[inaudible]
WITNESSES HOST.
ANY WITNESSES A POST.
OUR MOTION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
THEIR SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT THE AUTHOR LIKE TO CLOSE
CHESTER RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
FACTORED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
EMOTION IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
WALDRON BLOOM AYE AYE BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO.
COMEY HERO AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
LACKEY NO LACKEY NO REVERSE.
REAVIS AYE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
WORLD THE BILL STILL NEEDS ONE
VOTE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN AND
WE WILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE'S SENATE
MCGUIRE.
S. B..
NINE TWENTY NINE WELCOME SIR NOW
GET TO TREAT YOU LIKE YOU
TREATED ME THIS MORNING HAY THEY
WERE GEHRY NICELY AND THEY DO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALLOW ME TO BE
HERE AT WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY CAPABLE STAFF.
UP FOR ALL THE WORK WE ARE STILL
UPSET THAT MR MCDONALD HAS COME
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY FROM US
SENATE GOVERNMENT FIVE THAT.
I TALKED WHAT A WONDERFUL PICK
UP IN DEATH AND TAXES GUY SO
CONGRATULATIONS --
IN THAT TO THE COMMITTEE AND OF
COURSE MISS MCDONALD'S WELL
THANK YOU CAN MISTER CHAIR SP
NINE TWENTY NINE IS IMPORTANT
BUT RELATIVELY SIMPLE BILL.
FOCUSING ON TRANSPARENCY THIS
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IS
NOT RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES
CALIFORNIANS OVER TWO THOUSAND
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THAT OPERATE A SLEW OF VITAL
SERVICES FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
SUCH AS PROVIDING WATER AND
WASTEWATER FIRE PROTECTION PARKS
IN TRANSIT.
HOWEVER AT LESS THAN HALF OF ALL
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS ACTUALLY
OF A WEBSITE.
IT'S BEEN NINE TWENTY NINE WILL
REQUIRE EVERY INDEPENDENT
SPECIAL DISTRICT CREATE
INCONSISTENT CONSISTENTLY
MAINTAIN A WEBSITE.
WITH SPECIFIC AND DETAILED
INFORMATION BY CHEN REFERS.
TO TWENTY TWENTY WHILE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO RESIDENTS
ALL ACROSS THIS GREAT STATE.
CONSUMERS CONSUMERS MAY BE
UNAWARE OF WHAT THEIR LOCAL
SPECIAL DISTRICT DANCER EVEN HAD
A CONTACT.
IN THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THIS IS A INCLUDING NEED FOR
RESIDENTS TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
WHAT SERVICES ARE PROVIDED BY
THE DISTRICT.
INFORMATION IS ON THE DISTRICT'S
BUDGET.
TODAY THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT
THAT SPECIAL DISTRICTS MUST
CREATE AND OR MAINTAIN A WEBSITE
WHICH LEADS MANY RESIDENTS IN
THE DARK. FOR ISOLATED CASES
WHERE A SMALL SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ANY UNABLE TO MAINTAIN A WEBSITE
DUE TO HARDSHIP.
HAD THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR
EXEMPTION BASED ON DETAILED
FINDINGS.
IT'S TIME TO SHINE A LIGHT ON
THE MACHINE IN THESE DISTRICTS
AND PROVIDE THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA THE TRANSPARENCY THEY
DESERVE.
A MISTER CHAIR I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY DON'T GIVE INTIMACY THANK
YOU MISTER GIVENS FROM THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
THEY HAVE BEEN A FANTASTIC
PARTNER I IN HAVE A BROUGHT THIS
IDEA FORWARD.
AND IT'S ONCE A THANK YOU --
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THEIR I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT
OF LITERATURE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A TESTIMONY
LIKE PROVIDE YES AS CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
AND WELCOME TO THE NEWEST
DELUDE GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD --
AND THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON
HELPING TO CRAFT THE LANGUAGE --
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT THAT
MEASURE THIS IS A TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE THAT
WE'RE BRINGING FOR FOR OUR FOR
OUR OWN MEMBERSHIP ROAD SPECIAL
DISTRICTS --
AS THE THE CENTER SAID THIS WILL --
SHED SOME ADDITIONAL LIGHT ON
OUR SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT THAT
HAVEN'T HAD WEBSITES.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME IT
PROVIDES --
TO AN EXEMPTION FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THROUGH FOUR FOUR
SIGNIFICANT REASONS ARE NOT ABLE
TO HAVE A WEBSITE WHICH MIGHT
INCLUDE.
NOT HAVING INTERNET ACCESS WHERE
THEY ARE THE MOST WITH A REMOTE
AREAS OF THE STATE --
CSTA AND THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES FOR A LONG
TIME THROUGH THE PARTNERSHIP OF
THE SPECIAL DISTRICT LEADERSHIP
FOUNDATION --
HAVE BEEN OFFERING SCHOLARSHIPS
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS --
TO CREATE AND MAINTAIN WEBSITES
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THOSE
EFFORTS TO TRY TO ASSIST
DISTRICTS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
WITH THIS BILL --
IT WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURE'S JEAN HER STEERED
HIM BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS ALREADY
HAVE THIS REQUIREMENT WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF SENATE MCGUIRE
SPELL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES I CAN
MEET ON BEHALF OF BEACH CITIES
HELP DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
THEY HAVE LOTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE A MOTION THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION FROM OF THE CHAIR
OF TO PASS [inaudible]
MOTION.
WITH SOMEBODY LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION NINE MISTER GABER
[inaudible]
YOU.
THANK YOU REVENUE MOTION AND
SECOND.
AND LET'S A LITTLE.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE MISTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FUTURE INTO
WAS A THANK YOU TO THE STAFF
RATHER WORK AT AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK IN THE TERM AS
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PRETTY MUCH.
THE MOTION AS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY.
WALDRON BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON LACKEY.
LACKEY I READ THIS.
REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HIGH.
THANK YOU YOUR VOTE UP.
FIVE ZERO AND IT --
MISTER ALLEN AND I THINK --
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT THE SP
NIGHT.
SIXTY THREE IF THAT'S RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER BLOOM AGUILAR CARRY.
YEAH THAT CLOSER FROM HER NAME
SUDDENLY GOT LONGER [inaudible]
UNIVERSITY --
LET ME LET ME START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS ANALYSIS
IN AGREEING TO THE TACTICAL
AMENDMENT THAT'S OUTLINED A
COMMENT.
FOR OF YOUR NOW SEES MEMBERS IT
RELATIVE TO THE TERMINOLOGY
WHICH OUTLINES A DISH THE
AUDITING REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE BILL.
SO SP.
NINE SIXTY THREE REPEALS A
SECTION THE WATER COULD PLACING
A TEN MILLION DOLLAR CAP ON THE
GENERAL RESERVE FUND OF THE
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT.
IT REQUIRES THAT A MINIMUM OF
80% OF THE RESERVE FUND BE
EXPENDED SPECIFICALLY. FOR WATER
PURCHASES.
THESE RESTRICTIONS WERE PUT IN
PLACE EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO IN THE
WAKE OF A STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT
THAT FOUND THE WATER PLEDGE
INDUSTRY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S ASSESSMENT RATES.
WERE TOO HIGH THAT THE DISTRICT
MAINTAINED EXCESSIVE.
CASH RESERVES.
NOW NO OTHER INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICT IS SUBJECT TO
RESTRICTION ON ITS RESERVES.
AND IN THE YEARS SINCE THESE
RESTRICTIONS WERE IMPOSED.
THE WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT
THE ONLY WATER PUNCH FOR
DISTURBING THE STATE THAT'S I'M
KNOW JUST AS THE W. ARE D..
HAS SUBSEQUENTLY WON MULTIPLE
AWARDS FOR ITS FISCAL PRACTICES
AND TRANSPARENCIES.
SO THEY ARE THEY'VE GOT THEIR
ACT TOGETHER O. AFTER A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME AND I THINK WE'RE
NOW AT THE PLACE WHERE WE CAN.
AND WE CAN CHANGE AROUND SOME OF
THESE RULES IN IN A WAY THAT
WILL ACTUALLY MEET.
THE CURRENT STATE OF PLAY IN
TERMS OF WATER PROCUREMENT SO ME
EXPLAIN HOW THAT THE RULES RIGHT
NOW ARE ARE.
CRITICS IN CHALLENGES FIRST OF
ALL THE RESTRICTIONS THAT
PREVENTED THE WRT FROM
ACCUMULATING.
I NECESSARILY HIRE RESERVE
LEVELS IN WATER THE WATER
PURCHASE REQUIREMENT.
MADE SENSE AT THE TIME BUT NOW I
TIMES AND GROUNDWATER
REPLENISHING BEST PRACTICES IF
CHANGE SO FLUCTUATIONS IN COST.
AND IN RELIABILITY OF SUPPLY
HAVE [inaudible]
PRACTICAL NEED TO BECOME
INDEPENDENT OF IMPORTED WATER
SHIFTING INSTEAD TO THE
PRODUCTION OF LOCAL RELIABLE
SUPPLIES FOR PURPOSES OF
REPLENISHING THE CENTRAL WEST
COAST GROUND WATER BASINS.
SO THE IDEA WAS AT THE TIME THEY
WANTED THE MONEY TO GO TOWARD
WATER PURCHASES BY THERE'S NOW.
A LOT MORE --
OF A PUSH TOWARD LOCAL
PRODUCTION.
AND SO THAT THERE'S JUST BEEN A
SHIFT IN THE IN THE WAY THAT
THEY'VE BEEN THAT THEY COME TO
SEE THEIR BUSINESS MODEL AND IT.
AND IT'S VERY MUCH A COMPLIANCE
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL BEST
PRACTICES NOUN A COURSE IN FOR
THOSE WHO ARE FROM THE AREA
YOU'LL YOU'LL LIKE THE FACT THAT
WERE.
I'M TRYING.
TO REDUCE LOS ANGELES'S RELIANCE
ON OTHER REGIONS FOR WATER SO
THE WB'S WATER INDEPENDENCE NOW
NGUYEN.
W. AYE AND PROGRAM AIMS TO
ELIMINATE THE NEED TO PURCHASE
IMPORTED WATER FROM.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND FROM THE
COLORADO RIVER FOR GROUNDWATER
REPLENISHMENT.
AND ONCE FULLY ESTABLISHED THE
DEPUTIES REGIONS I GROUNDWATER
BASES WILL WILL COMPLETELY BE
LOCALLY SUSTAINABLE LOCALLY
SOURCED WHICH IS THAT DOT THE
PLANET'S OF ONE I THINK WE OUGHT
TO SUPPORT.
SO THIS BILL PERMITS THE WB TO
BETTER MANAGE ITS FINANCES FOR
CHANGING WATER CONDITIONS AND
DEMANDS.
IT PROVIDES A W. THE ABILITY TO
SHIFT AWAY FROM OUTDATED
RELIABILITY AND WATER IMPORTS TO
MODERN MODEL OF LOCAL SOURCING
AND SUSTAINABILITY WHILE.
PLANNING FOR SUBSTANTIAL
OPERATING COSTS THAT IT WILL
ENCOURAGE FINANCING ITS ADVANCE
WATER TREATMENT FACILITIES THE
BILL WILL LIMIT THE ULTIMATE
PRICE TO TAXPAYERS.
BY PERMITTING COST TO BE ADDRESS
ON A PAY AS YOU GO BASIS RATHER
THAN THROUGH MORE EXPENSIVE DEBT
FINANCING THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION ITS GUARD GOING TO
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NIGHT.
RESPECT YES RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SINCE WE
WERE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB READ
WITH READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
ANY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
FATHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY DURING HAVE A MOTION.
WE NEED A MOTION A SECOND.
NEVER LOOK A THEM.
HOW CARRIER MOTIONLESS SECONDS --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY JUST
WANTED TO MENTION HOW EXCITING
IT IS TO HAVE THESE I'M TOO
FANTASTIC NEW MEMBERS FROM LOS
ANGELES.
I IN THE LEGISLATURE IN ON YOUR
COMMITTEE AND AND THEN.
I'M PUT FOR ORGAN BOTH YOU AND I
VERY MUCH RESPECT FAST FOR LIVE
ON THIS BILL WELL I GUESS THE WB
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THEM
THE BILL FLORIDA SENATOR ALAN A
SPORT RUNNING W. ARE DE SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN ITS USE OF
RESERVES.
AM PLEASED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS THAT YOU ARE
DOING SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
OKAY --
SECRETARY PUT FIVE WHOLE THE
RULE EMOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE.
GRIEVOUS.
REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL.
PROPEL AYE.
OKAY BILLS US IT'S REALLY REALLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A GOOD
AFTERNOON.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER --
SEVEN CENTER LEYVA SP ONE ONE
FOUR FIVE WELCOME SENATOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND NEW MEMBERS WELCOME.
ON HIS COULD HAVE GOOD NEW
PEOPLE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FIVE
AUTHORIZES ENHANCED
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS OR E. I. F. DIS TO DO
MAINTENANCE ON THE FACILITIES
THAT THEY BUILT.
BAFTAS ARE AN IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FINANCE TOOL FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO MOVE
COMMUNITY PROJECTS FORWARD.
CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN CREATE
E. I. F. DIS TO BUILD WATER
SYSTEMS.
CHILD CARE FACILITIES PARKS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AMONG SEVERAL
OTHER COMMUNITY BENEFIT PROJECTS.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER TWENTY
FIVE EEF DIS ACROSS THE STRAIGHT
STATE THAT ARE EITHER APPROVED
OR IN THE STUDY PHASE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
CONSIDERING ESTABLISHING E. IFT
ARE FACING THE CURRENT
LIMITATION ON MAINTAINING THE
PROJECTS THAT WILL BE BUILT.
AS YOU KNOW LONG TERM
MAINTENANCE COSTS ARE OFTEN
TIMES OVERLOOKED IN THESE TYPE
OF DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS.
PRESENTLY III OF DIS CANNOT PAY
FOR MAINTENANCE ROUTINE REPAIRS
OR OPERATIONS THIS SITUATION IS
PROBLEMATIC SINCE MANY
COMMUNITIES WILL NEED FUNDS FROM
THESE DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN THE
STRUCTURES OVER TIME.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FIVE ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PRO
ACTIVELY BUDGET MAINTENANCE
COSTS FROM THE I FD REVENUES
RATHER THAN RELY ON VOLATILE
GENERAL FUNDS.
VERY VERY CLEAR THE BILL DOES
NOT ASK FOR NEW FUNDS TAXES OR
FEES IT WILL HOWEVER ALLOW THE
AYE IF THESE TO MAINTAIN
FACILITIES PROPERLY AND PROTECT
LOCAL TAXPAYER INVESTMENTS IN
THE LONG TERM.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS AARON LOW.
MORAL THEY FIT RIGHT AARON RIGHT.
UP WHO IS THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING DIRECTOR
FOR THE CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO
AND IS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
[inaudible]
AARON.
AND HERE'S A GENTLEMAN HAS USE
THE TOOL SO WELCOME AND THANK
YOU.
KNOW THAT'S TRUE --
SO AGAIN THERE.
THE MEASURE WAS SACRAMENTO SO --
WE WERE THANK YOU WE WERE THE
FIRST -- STE
A CITY IN THE STATE --
TO FORMING I'VE D. WERE NOW IN
THE OF USING IT --
TO BUILD ALL SORTS OF PROJECTS
SO -- THAT
ISSUE IS THE ISSUE FOR WAS
SACRAMENTO IS AN ONGOING
MAINTENANCE BUT I CAN SPEAK FOR
CALOTES MEMBERSHIP IT IS AN
ISSUE ACROSS THE STATUS THEY
CITIES LOOK AT THIS TOOL.
SO I WANT TO GIVE A COUPLE OF
PRACTICAL EXAMPLES FIRST DUB
KIND OF FRAMING THE PROBLEMS ONE
CITIES I DON'T THINK A LOT OF
YOU HAVE LOOKED GOVERNMENT
BACKGROUNDS YOU CAN APPRECIATE
THIS WERE REALLY GOOD AT
BUILDING THINGS.
BUT IT'S VERY HARD TO BUDGET
MONEY FOR MAINTENANCE THAT'S
JUST A FACT OF LIFE IN CITY
GOVERNMENT --
NOW THE ID'S ARE IN PLACE THEY
ARE ALSO CONTEMPLATED BE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL OR TO WORK ON
PROJECTS ACROSS.
AGENCY LINES AND SO THAT'S
ANOTHER IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL SO
JUST FOR EXAMPLE WERE BUILDING A
PROJECT WAS THAT THE CITY WHAT
OF SACRAMENTO TO BRIDGE --
THAT WILL REPLACE THE OLD AYE
STREET BRIDGE OF SO BLOODY
PRIVATELY WITH THAT.
THAT PROJECT IS BY ITS NATURE TO
SEE PROJECT IT'S GONNA BE VERY
EXPENSIVE TO MAINTAIN AND OUR A
I'VE THE WILL HELP FINANCE IT IS
IT LIKELY TO BE MAINTAINED AND
OPERATED BY SOMETHING THAT MIGHT
BE A GPA.
THIS CONCEPT WOULD APPLY HERE IS
THAT THE I'VE D. COULD ACTUALLY
BUDGET ONGOING FUNDS.
THROUGH A MAINTENANCE AGREEMENT
WITH THE JPA.
PAGE YOU GO MANY.
THE IDEA WOULD GENERATE I'D TAKE
CARE OF THE MAINTENANCE FOR THE
LIFESPAN OF THE BRIDGE AND
THAT'S A MUCH MORE RESPONSIBLE
WAY OF BUDGETING FOR MAINTENANCE
THAN RELYING ON ONGOING.
AND LIMITED REVENUES FROM
GENERAL FUND BUDGET SO --
WITH THE I'M HERE TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE OF AND
AND RESPECT WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS IS ABOUT LIKE I
SAID A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
CALLIN CHINE.
AND IN ITS EFFORT TO BE A LEADER
ON THIS SIDE TAX INCREMENT ISSUE
STATEWIDE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
SING IN AND IS THERE ANYONE IN.
OH OKAY THERE'S A SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I MATTHEW
HARD TO THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION.
YOU PROBABLY NORMALLY SEE ME ON
THE SAME SIDE OF THE TABLE THIS
GENTLEMAN ON THINGS LIKE THIS.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THAT YEAH IF
THE IS SOMETHING THAT'S ON THE
AND EVOLVING ISSUE AYE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
IT.
AYE OUR MEMBERS --
ARE DEFERRING TO CAL AT ON THIS.
ONE BUT WE BELIEVE THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE CITY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO
FUND THE THINGS THAT THEY BUILD
SO -- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
EARLIER I DON'T THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
SING THEN WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION NEWMAN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF AT THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
UNFORTUNATELY TO THE BILL TODAY.
AND WHILE MISTER HERGER OF
MENTION THAT USUALLY WE'RE ON
THE SAME SIDE OF TABLE LEAST ON
THIS BILL WE ARE AT THE TABLE
WHICH IS GOOD NEWS --
MEMBERS IT'S BEEN STATED THAT
THE INTENT OF THE PROPONENTS IS
TO ENSURE THAT HE OF IDEAS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO USE PAGE YOU GO
FUNDS TO FUND MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS THAT LAST LESS THAN
FIFTEEN YEARS.
IF THAT IS TRULY THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATION WE HAVE NO
OBJECTION TO THAT AND WILL IN
FACT PROPER OPPOSITION.
HOWEVER THAT'S NOT WHAT WE THINK
THE BILL SAYS.
WHAT THE BILL DOES PROHIBIT
ROUTINE MAINTENANCE FROM BEING
PAID WITH BOND FUNDS WE DO THINK
IT CREATES A LOOPHOLE WHEREBY
THE ONGOING OR CAPITALIZE COST
TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC CAPITAL
FACILITIES?
UNQUOTE WHICH WE BELIEVE TO BE
PROJECTS WITH LIFE CYCLE COSTS
OF LESS THAN FIFTEEN YEARS COULD
IN FACT BE FUNDED WITH BOND
DOLLARS.
MEMBERS WE'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED
THAT BONDS OF ALL TYPES SHOULD
RECEIVE TWO THIRDS VOTER
APPROVAL AS ONGOING DEBT.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE SPENT ON
CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT LAST
THOUGH AND FOR THE BLIND AND NOT
BASED ON ON GOING REACHING
MAINTENANCE OF ANY KIND --
AS I MENTIONED PROPONENTS
INITIATE CARE DO APPEAR TO BE
SOMEWHAT ON THE SAME PAGE HERE.
I DID REQUEST COMMITTEE STAFF
THAT THE BILL BE PUT OVER TILL
LATER THIS MONTH HOWEVER THAT
OFFER WAS REJECTED SO
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE TO BE
HERE.
TEAIRRA SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL BUT WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
IS THERE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE I AM I AM --
IT WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
OKAY -- SO
DEPENDENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
OF A SECOND.
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SUSPECT WESTERN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M TODAY I
RECOMMEND --
DO PASS ON THIS I WANT TO SAY IS
IREALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL WE
HAD AN INFORMATION HEARING LAST
YEAR WE TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT
WAYS TO FIND YOU FINANCING.
AND OF INFINITE.
LA PEOPLE WERE NOT USING.
THIS AT ALL AND SO I APPRECIATE
YOU MOVING --
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER WE BILL WE CAN MAINTAIN
IT AND WE'VE SEEN THIS GOING ON
IN ON FOR YEARS AND SO I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING AS
WELL AS WHAT SACRAMENTO --
YOU'VE DONE SOME REALLY GOOD
STUFF AND WE LOOK TO YOU TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND MAKE
SURE THESE BILLS ACTUALLY WORK
THAT WE TRY TO PASS UP.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUNG
CHAIR YES SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO REVERSE [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO [inaudible]
VOTES.
BILLS OUT FIVE TO TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BIG MEN CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
LOOK IF WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
CONSECUTIVE MOTION OFFER THE
PROMOTION A SECOND [inaudible]
SECRETARY COHEN.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE AND SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY TWO GLAZER TO BE RE REFER
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL.
NINE OH SEVEN CANNELLA TO BE RE
REFER TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SP.
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE HARDWARE
CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
REAVIS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I I CONCERTS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO WE HAVE ONE OTHER --
ONE S. B. TEN THIRTY FIVE
JACKSON [inaudible]
ON CALL.
CURRENT VOTE IS. FOR TWO TO
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
BILLS OUT.
SIX TO LOOK AHEAD TO ADD ONS.
SERGEANT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
MISSING MEMBERS WE DO ADULTS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY TWO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WALDRON [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
SLAPPED ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATE
BILL [inaudible]
NINE FOURTEEN WALDRON
[inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
TING.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SENATE BILL.
NINE TWENTY NINE AGUIAR-CURRY I
AM VERY HURRY I WALDRON
[inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
I REMEMBER [inaudible]
FIVE WALDRON [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SIX NUMBER.
SEVEN ITS IT PER RIGHT NOW TO
MAKE IT MEMBERS BACK.
OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THE ROLE FOR FIVE MINUTES
AND TAKE A BREATHER HERE BEFORE
WE START THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING
[inaudible]
SOMETIMES [inaudible]
W. [inaudible]
WE
YOU.
BUT A LOT OF
THIS IS FOR THE DAY
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GOING TO TAKE ABOUT A TEN MINUTE
RECESS HERE BEFORE WE START
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
BUT WAITING FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE TO ATTEND SO YOU DON'T
MIND STRETCH HAVE LESS WATER AND
WILL BE BACK HERE SOON THANK YOU